the truth of genetic differences
no matter what the
between groups
is is a
painful
harmful potentially potentially
dangerous thing this is let me ask you
to this
question whether there's bell curve or
any research on
race differences
can that be used to increase the amount
of racism in the world
can that be used to increase the amount
of hate in the world do you think about
this kind of stuff i've thought about
this a lot not as a scientist but as a
person
and
my sense is
there is such
enormous
reservoirs of hate and racism
that have nothing to do with scientific
knowledge of the data
that speak against that
that
no i i don't
i don't want to give racist groups of
veto power over what scientists study
if you think that the differences
and by the way virtually no one
disagrees that there are differences in
scores it's all about what causes them
and how to fix it
so if you think this is a cultural
problem then you must ask the problem
what do you want do you want to change
anything about the culture or are you
okay with
the culture because you don't feel it's
appropriate to change a person's culture
so are you okay with that and the fact
that that may lead to disadvantages in
in school achievement
it's a question
are if you think it's environmental
what are the environmental
parameters that can be fixed i'll tell
you one
lead in you know led from gasoline in
the atmosphere lead in paint lead in in
water
that's an environmental toxin that
society has the means to
and they should yeah just to sort of
trying to find some um
insight and conclusion to this very
difficult topic
uh is there
been research on environment versus
genetics nature versus nurture on this
question of race differences
there is not no one wants to do this
research it's first of all it's hard
research to do second of all it's it's a
minefield no one wants to spend their
career on it tenured people don't want
to do it let alone students
the way i talk about it
well before i tell you the way i talk
about i want to say one more thing about
jensen
he was once asked by a journalist
straight out are you a racist
his answer was very interesting his
answer was i've thought about that a lot
and i've concluded it doesn't matter
this now i i know what he meant by this
the guts to say that wow he was a very
unusual person i think he had a touch of
asperger's syndrome to tell you the
truth because i i saw him in many
circumstances he would be canceled on
twitter immediately with that sentence
yeah but what he what he meant was he
had a hypothesis
yeah and with respect to group
differences he called it the default
hypothesis he said whatever factors
affect individual intelligence are
likely the same factors that affect
group differences it was the default but
it was a hypothesis
it should be tested and if it turned out
empirical test didn't support the
hypothesis he was happy to move on to
something else
he was absolutely committed to that
scientific ideal
that that
it's an empirical question
we should look at it and let's see what
happens the scientific method cannot be
racist from his perspective it doesn't
matter what the scientists
if they
if they follow the scientific method
it doesn't matter what they believe and
if they are biased and they
consciously or unconsciously
bias the data
other people will come along to
replicate it they will fail and the
process over time
will work
so let me push back on this
idea
because psychology to me
is full of gray areas
and
what i've observed about psychology
even replication crisis aside
is that something about the media
something about journalism
something about the the virality of
ideas in the public sphere
they
misinterpret
they take up things from studies
willfully or from ignorance misinterpret
findings
and tell narratives around
that i personally believe for me i'm not
saying that broadly about science but
for me
it's my responsibility to anticipate the
ways in which findings will be
misinterpreted
so i've had i thought about this a lot
because i
published papers on
uh semi-autonomous vehicles and
uh those
you know cars people dying cars
there's people that have written me a
letter saying emails nobody writes
letters i wish they did
uh that i have blood in my hands because
of things that i would say positive or
negative there's consequences in the
same way when you're a researcher for
intelligence i'm sure you might get
emails
or
at least people might believe that a
finding of your study
is going to be used by a large number of
people to increase the amount of hate in
the world
i think there's some responsibility on
scientists
but for me i think there's a great
responsibility uh
to anticipate the ways
things will be misinterpreted and there
you have to first of all decide whether
you want to say a thing at all
or do the study at all publish the study
at all and to the words with which you
explain it
it's uh
i find this on twitter a lot actually
which is when i when i write a tweet i'm
usually just doing so innocently
i
i'll
i'll i'll write it you know it takes me
like five seconds to write it or
whatever 30 seconds to write it and then
i'll think all right i like close my
eyes at the open and try to see how will
the world
interpret this like what are the ways in
which this will be misinterpreted and
i'll sometimes adjust that tweet to see
like
yeah so in my mind it's clear but that's
because it's my mind from which this
tweet came but you have to think in a
fresh mind that sees this
uh and it's spread across
a large
number of other minds how will
the interpretation morph i mean for a
tweet it's a silly thing it doesn't
matter but for
a scientific
um paper and study and finding
i think it matters so i don't know well
i don't know what your thoughts about
that because maybe for jensen
uh the data is there
what do you want me to do this is a
scientific
process has been carried out
if you think the data was polluted by
bias do other studies that reveal the
bias
uh but the data is there and we like i
have
would i'm not a poet
i'm not a uh literary right like what do
you want me to do i'm just presenting
you the data what do you think on that
spectrum what's the role of a scientist
the reason i do podcasts yeah the reason
i write
books for the public
is to explain what i think the data mean
and what i think the data don't mean
i don't do very much on twitter other
than to retweet uh references to papers
yes i don't think it's my role to
explain these because they're
complicated they're nuanced
but when you decide
not to do a scientific study because
you're
or not to publish a result because
you're afraid the
result could be
could be harmful or insensitive
that's not an unreasonable thought
and
people will
make different conclusions and decisions
about that i wrote about this i wrote uh
i i'm the editor of a journal called
intelligence which published which
publishes scientific papers
sometimes we publish papers on group
differences
those papers sometimes are controversial
these papers are written for a
scientific audience they're not written
for the twitter audience so i don't
promote them very much on
on twitter
but
in a scientific paper
you have to now choose your words
carefully also because those papers are
picked up
uh by non-scientists
by writers of various kinds and you have
to be available to discuss
what you're saying and what you're not
saying
sometimes
you are successful at having a a good
conversation like we are today that's
that doesn't start out pejorative
other times i've been asked to
participate in debates where my role
would be to justify race science
well you can see
just start out
you know and that was a bbc request that
i had that i received i have so much
it's a love-hate relationship mostly
hate with these shallow journal uh
journalism organizations so they would
want to use you
as a kind of in a debate setting to
communicate as to like there is raise
differences between groups and make that
into debate yes and put you in a role of
um justifying racism justification
they're asking me to divorce is like
educating about this this field of the
science of intelligence yeah i i want to
say one more thing before we get off the
the normal distribution you also asked
me what is the science after the bell
curve
and the short answer is there's not much
new work but whatever work there is
supports the idea that there still are
group differences
it's arguable whether those differences
have diminished at all or not
and there is still a major problem in
underperformance in for school
achievement
for many uh mis disadvantaged and
minority students and there so far is no
way to fix it
you